Sophie benabi qui est notre invité
Mathilde si vous me le permettez voilà
je m'installe dans notre petit salon de
tv78 alors vous êtes praticienne en
naayour Veda à guoncour bonsoir déjà
alors vous partagez vos astuces sur les
réseaux sociaux sur votre compte qui
s'appelle Les Aventures vertes de Sophie
qui compte plus de 40000 abonnés sur
Instagram et on va parler avec vous donc
de l'Ayurveda qui sera sans doute un un
allié pour nos ivelinois durant ces
fêtes de fin d'année est-ce que vous
pouvez déjà dire en quelques mots c'est
quoi l'Ayurveda oui bien sûr alors c'est
une médecine en fait indienne qui prend
en compte l'être dans sa globalité et
qui donne une grande part en fait à
l'alimentation pour pouvoir prendre soin
de soi alors on aura l'occasion de
parler tout à l'heure des bienfaits sur
le corps humain de l'Ayurveda alors il y
a un bienfait qui est en tout cas on
peut l'avancer déjà digestif il peut
nous être utile pendant la la période de
fête alors vous avez vous êtes venu avec
quelques petits ingrédients parce que
vous allez nous préparer un apérit
aillour vé qui va nous aider justement à
bien passer ses fêtes à se détoxifier le
corps après les les repas copieux
expliquez-moi ce que vous allez nous
préparer là oui alors c'est à base en
fait de trois ingrédients donc c'est
extrêmement facile à refaire donc du
gingembre du citron et du sel rose de
l'Himalaya et en fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle un Dipana en Ayurveda c'est un
apéritif qui va aider à bien métaboliser
le repas parce que on va avoir pas mal
de choses grasses lourdes frit sur la
table et donc ça va permettre justement
d'allumer un petit peu ce feu digestif
pour éviter de entir en kilosé d'avoir
les léthargies de piquer un petit peu du
nez après le repas donc voilà on
augmente en fait le feu digestif et on
permet d'éviter d'avoir trop de toxine
dans le dans le corps alors je
connaissais le gingembre le citron ça ça
va encore le sel rose je connaissais pas
c'est quoi sa particularité alors en
fait il est beaucoup plus doux que le
sel lambda qu'on peut trouver en
commerce et il s'accommode vraiment très
bien parce que vous allez voir qu'avec
le citron et les Lambre c'est déjà assez
fort donc ce type de sel permet un petit
peu d'adoucir et de pas être trop
prononcé et pourquoi alors ces
ingrédients sont-ils bénéf pour nous
voilà qu'on on les prend dans leur dans
leur entièreté que ce soit le le
gingembre le citron le le sel pourquoi
ils vont être bénéfiques pour nous alors
c'est surtout cette convergence des
trois qui est très intéressant parce
qu'en fait le salé l'acide et le piquant
c'est trois saveurs en Ayurvéda qui
aident à booster le métabolisme et à
éviter que les toxines soient trop
importantes dans le dans le corps et
dans le système digestif donc c'est très
intéressant de les prendre ensemble mais
on peut aussi les prendre de manière
éparce par exemple un jus de citron avec
de l'eau chaude ça sera tout à fait
aussi une façon de prendre finin de son
système digestif avant les fêtes ou
pendant les fêtes ou juste une infusion
de gingembre c'est tout à fait aussi
possible mais si vous mixez les trois
vous avez encore plus de potentialité et
de puissance alors on va vous laisser
dans notre salon de tv78 préparer
tranquillement ce petit apéritif et bien
sûr mati tout à l'heure on goûtera je
pense que c'est c'est ce qu'on attend
tous et Grégory Canalis est reparti dans
le petit salon au côté de Sophie benabi
qui nous prépare un apéritif ayurvédique
c'est un apéritif ayurvédique pour et
bien bien passer la la période juste
après le repas des fêtes à base de
gingembre de citron de sel de rose de
l'Himalaya on peut aussi ajouter du miel
hein c'est ça on peut agrémenter
exactement on peut ajouter du miel pour
adoucir un petit peu le goût et pour les
bec un peu plus sucrés alors vous les
avez préparé on a parlé tout à l'heure
des bienfaits de Cha ingrédient du
gingembre du citron du sel rose de
l'Himalaya est-ce que le fait de les
associer ça va décupler les les effets
bénéfiques justement oui parce qu'en
fait le sel va booster la salivation ce
qui va entretenir la digestion va
l'amorcer le citron c'est un détoxifiant
assez puissant au même titre que le
gingembre et le fait de les associer
ensemble permet d'avoir ce ce côté un
peu enfin allumer le feu en quelque
sorte intérieur et détox aussi derrière
pour bien métaboliser le plat donc c'est
bien les associer ensemble alors cet
apéritif vous l'avez préparé là pendant
nos différents magnetos et en fait
finalement vous l'avez terminé donc
c'est très rapide finalement à faire
ultra rapide comment vous l'avez
préparer expliquez-nous alors hyper
simple en fait vous coupez des petites
rondelles assez fines de gingembre vous
pouvez aussi avoir la version râpée si
on préfère avoir le goût râpé du
gingembre et vous mettez dessus en fait
du jus de citron donc juste un petit peu
pour que ça recouvre la la lame de la
lamelle de gingembre et vous ajoutez
dessus une petite pincée de sel et puis
vous le mangez comme ça en fait 30
minutes avant de prendre votre repas de
Noël donc ça vous a pris à peu près 5
minutes monre en main oh même pas 2
minutes ultra rapide et tous ces
ingrédients se les procurent facilement
alors oui vous pouvez les acheter alors
c'est mieux de prendre en magasin bio si
vous pouvez pour éviter d'avoir bien sûr
les pesticides du dans le gingembre et
dans le citron sinon euh dans un mag
enfin en grande surface vous pouvez tout
à fait en trouver le sel de l'Himalaya
c'est plutôt en magasin biologique euh
c'est très difficile à trouver en en
grande surface ou alors sur Internet
est-ce que c'est à des prix abordables
qu'on les trouve le sel de l'Himalaya il
est très abordable c'est vraiment très
plus cher pour euh 200 g vous vous payez
à peu près 3 € donc c'est vraiment très
peu et vous les conseillez de de le
consommer quand après le repas juste
après un jour après alors vraiment avant
le repas c'est avant c'est l'apéritif
qui est avant le repas avant de prendre
l'entrée par exemple vous mangez ça 30
minutes avant il faut bien 30 minutes
pour que la combustion se mette un petit
peu en place au niveau du système
digestif ou alors on peut le prendre
aussi après le repas pareil 30 minutes
après le repas donc c'est soit on va
dire pour préparer le repas soit juste
après on va dire pour le désamorcer si
si je puux dire et une fois que c'est
préparé est-ce qu'il faut le consommer à
la minute est-ce qu'il faut le consommer
assez rapidement euh vous pouvez le
laisser un petit peu macérer pour que le
jus de citron avec le sel et le
gingembre travaill ensemble donc vous
pouvez le laisser reposer par exemple là
je je l'aurais fait donc pour 30 minutes
enfin 30 minutes après manger ça aurait
été par donc je peux le faire un petit
peu en avance comme ça prend pas de
temps on peut aussi le faire à la
dernière minute si on préfère on peut le
consommer tout de suite du coup on peut
le consommer tout de suite je vous
laisse retirer votre micro on va aller
rejoindre les autres en plateau pour
leur faire goûter je vais vous filer un
petit coup de main
hop on a hâte de goûter ça allez-y et
vous pouvez vous mettre à côté de
Gabriel sur le plateau et on va bah
distribuer à chacun sa petite bouché
aussi Mathilde faire goûter également à
George schmi voi merci merci beaucoup ah
oui cure et du coup il reste pour moi ou
et on mange comme alors oui est-ce qu'on
s'attend c'est ça m tout mês
avoir un peu de feu dans la bouche
d'accord c'est très pratique pour
présenter après que j'allais dire ça
permet de mieux jouer ok pour jouer de
la F de pou ah oui c'est fort c'est fort
mais c'est le but je vais devenir
tout ah ou
faut pas en manger trop un petit peu
j'ai tout mangé voà mais je pense que du
coup le
gingembre oui ça détoxifie
bien petite réaction Clara quand vous
aurez récupéré votre voix vous confirme
le piquant j'ai l'impression votre tête
le confir rouge lesux qui
piquéau un petit peu on sent la détox là
tout de suite on la sent là pour le coup
du coup là on va préparer un peu notre
digestion du pas de ce soir déjà B tout
à fait il faut manger dans les demihe
c'est mieux c'est mieux d'accord ok oui
sinon le feu va trop brûler on a compris
ce qu'il faut faire après l'émission ben
merci beaucoup en tout cas Sophie benavi
pour cette dégustation
pimentée Sophie benamille on le rappelle
qui est donc thérapeute en Ayurveda
installé à guyancour alors on a commencé
à à présenter tout à l'heure cette
médecine traditionnelle indienne
l'objectif c'est d'harmoniser le corps
et l'esprit pour le bien-être du cor
humain c'est ça exactement d'harmoniser
le corps l'esprit le mental pour que
tout fonctionne de concert et qu'on soit
bien dans ses baskets concrètement ça va
nous aider en quoi l'Ayurveda pour ces
fêtes de fin d'année alors ça va aider à
composer les repas de manière on va dire
intelligente dans le sens éviter de trop
obstruer son corps donc avec des choses
mais vraiment hyper simples et que tout
à chacun peut faire donc par exemple
éviter de boire froid à table parce que
le fait de boire froid en fait vous
allez éteindre votre feu digestif et
vous allez allez vous sentir lourd donc
on évite de mettre des glaçons dans son
verre on évite de boire des par exemple
un champagne trop trop froid donc c'est
quoi le mieux c'est température ambiante
est-ce qu'on peut boire chaudou ex on
peut boire chaud si on le souhaite alors
là c'est idéal donc pendant le repas par
exemple ou avant avec une petite
infusion d'épic par exemple c'est très
bien ou alors juste à température
ambiante ça sera parfait mais jamais
glacé et on évite les glaçons de de
préférence ensuite ça va être utiliser
les épices c'est ça on va les parsemer
sur nos aliments euh que ce soit notre
fois gras les viandes les poissons
desserts épic alors en fait chaque
aliment va avoir des affinetés avec des
épices particulières donc là pour
prendre un exemple ça peut être la crème
glacée les bûches de voilà de de Noël
donc là les épices qui vont être très
intéressantes pour les digérer ça va
être la cannelle qui va aider à digérer
le lactose des produits laitiers on va
avoir le saffran la noix de muscade le
gingembre qu'on a vu tout à l'heure qui
peut énormément aider aussi et le la
cardamom et après pour le fromage par
exemple si vous servez du fromage à
table vous pouvez aussi mettre par
exemple des graines de cumin qu'on
retrouve dans le fameux goudda au cumin
bon qui est peut-être un peu moins sympa
pour Noël mais qui est très intéressant
d'un point de vue aurvidique ou alors
des graines de fenouill en fait tout ce
qui va être un peu carminatif qui va
aider à à diminuer tout ce qui est
ballonnement va pouvoir aider à digérer
les choses lourdes donc j'ai cité la
crème glacée mais il y a aussi la viande
la viande donc la viande alors là c'est
peut-être un peu plus commun mais tout
ce qui va être ail romarin la sariette
le th ça ça va aider directement la
digestion ça va aider la digestion tout
ce qui est Aromat et épices aide à la
digestion et de préférence très bien
digérer son
repas effectivement dis à l'instant le
deuxème passe mieux le deè passe mieux
oui parce que le palais est beaucoup
plus habitué en fait et c'est un peu
anesthési
ai alors il y a un autre conseil qui
semble simple quand quand je l'ai lu
c'est de faire une petite marche juste
après le le repas exactement on y'y
pense pas forcément mais ça ça peut être
aussi pour le quotidien c'est de prendre
l'habitude d'aller marcher juste 15 à 20
minutes donc là par exemple si vous
faites Noël vous fêtez Noël à midi vous
prévoyez d'aller faire une petite balade
avec vos convives et vous allez vous
aérer et ça permet en fait d'entretenir
les mouvements du péristaltisme et donc
d'aider à bien digérer donc c'est
vraiment très simple mais hyper effic P
combi de temps environ il faut marcher
entre 15 à 20 minutes c'est le minimum
c'est déjà efficace après si vous faites
une heure c'est très bien et après avoir
mangé bien sûr et après avoir mangé
exactement oui oui c'est pour aider à la
dig balade digestive tout à fait
dominicale la plupart du temps et alors
il peut arriver que ces repas défit soit
arrosé alors on rappelle l'alcool est à
consommer avec modération mais justement
pour prévenir la gueule de bois pour
mieux la la digérer en quelque sorte
quel quels sont les les aliments quels
sont les conseils que vous pouvez donner
alors déjà ça va être d'éviter de manger
trop lourd pour pas trop congestionner
le foie le système digestif le pancréas
qui déjà travaille beaucoup par la
digestion de de l'alcool donc si vous
pouvez vous éviter d'ajouter du chocolat
de reboire de l'alcool derrière de
manger trop carnet donc trop de viande
par exemple au lendemain de fête donc
manger très léger des bouillons des
soupes des assiettes de légumes et puis
il y a une petite astuce c'est de
prendre une banane de l'écraser et de
mettre dedans du romarin on peut y
ajouter du curcuma et du poivre et ça en
fait ça va éviter qu'on perte trop de
potassium avec l'alcool en fait qui fait
fuiter le potassium et qui donne des
mauxs de tête et qui assèche aussi donc
ça permet auss a de réhydrater un petit
peu et de et d'éviter enfin de soutenir
un peu l'activité du foie qui est un peu
mise à mal par l'alcool avec le Romar
j'ai lu que le gingembre aussi avait un
rôle bénéfique finalement c'est
l'ingrédient miracle pendant C c'est un
peu l'ingrédient miracle antitoxine qui
qu'on peut utiliser vraiment en fait en
au début du repas pendant le repas et
même après le repas si on l'a assez
faite c'est tout gagné alors si on veut
aller plus loin sur
l'Ayurveda vous avez beaucoup écrit sur
le sujet il y a notamment ce livre qui
s'appelle le grand livre de
l'alimentation a ça a été publié en 2021
aux éditions Le Duc dedans on trouve en
somme tout un tas de conseils des
recettes aussi alors on trouve des
recettes tout ce qui est lecture en fait
de l'alimentation ayurvédique parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à savoir et
à connaître et en fait au final c'est
très abordable pour pour tout le monde
donc la cartographie des aliments
comment on fait une détox ayurvédique
comment on compose un plat ayurvédique
pour la famille c'est très voilà c'est
très pratio pratique pour le quotidien
et bien merci d'être venu en plateau S
benamier on précise d'ailleurs que c'est
une reconversion ça a été un peu une
passion l'Ayurveda pour vous oui un coup
de foudre un coup de foudre une
rencontre en fait et effectivement avant
j'étais ingénieur informatique et j'ai
tout quitté pour pour l'Ayurveda et si
on veut aller plus loin donc je disais
il y a ce livre il y a aussi vos réseaux
sociaux il y a un compte qui s'appelle
Les Aventures vertes de Sophie Instagram
TikTok Facebook et également YouTube on
peut retrouver des petits conseils au
jour le jour sur ce compte Instagram et
sur les autres comptes plus de 40000
abonnés he sur Instagram sur Instagram
sur YouTube sur TikTok et sur Facebook
40000 et une personne maintenant très
précis point précis en direct on aime la
la précision merci beaucoup Michel merci
Sophie ben merci beaucoup Sophie benabi
pour tous ces conseils